oh i'm naughty
you're a naughty naughty man naughty
i uh
you know i'm always here on the show
going hey man your movie's great this
movie's very funny oh thank you very
much very funny i mean that uh i saw it
a couple of nights ago i was laughing
through the whole thing and you uh you
wrote this movie i did yes yeah it's got
your sense of humor all the way through
it it's really very great oh thank you
very much the um there's just some stuff
that that is shocking when you first see
it it's uh and i think we need some
explanation here just so we warn people
but in this movie you take off your
shirt a lot yes well
well within the tradition of british and
canadian comedy
uh is
partial male nudity
they love to be naked that's lamey
well in this movie you've got about
60 pounds of chest hair yes just all
over the place yeah well it's it's
modeled after uh sean connery
who is uh
he's a yeti
the man is just uh
so covered in hair he could like knit
his chest you know
it's like a hair suit you know
and so you you saw because this movie is
really uh it's really poking fun of the
the spy john bond matt helm in like
flint
all the movies uh from the 60s because
you know they're
every swinger in the 60s was like
something by day like a tennis player
and then a secret agent at night right
like in the 70s it was like you know
they're a family by day and then they're
in a band by night you know that's a
partridge family josie and the pussycats
or even fred flintstone was in the way
outs you know right but in the 60s
everybody had to be a secret agent you
know yeah it was it was it was expected
that's what you do baby
yeah exclaiming
explain the uh
in the movie uh your swinger has uh very
cool guy women love them yes worst teeth
i've ever seen you had these incredible
prosthetic teeth well you know i hope
they were prosthetic teeth oh yeah okay
yeah no i uh
you know my parents are from liverpool
and uh they came to canada in 1956 and
in britain in the 60s you could be a
swinger and still have really bad teeth
it didn't matter
and uh you know britain won the war and
lost their teeth
and uh they kind of they view their
teeth as a vestigial organ like the
appendix
because they they eat about a metric ton
of sugar a day
and uh they fry everything yeah yeah i
mean if you still see rock stars today
you know from from britain who are
bajillionaires and they've just got like
you know stick for teeth just want to
say you've got the money go to the
dentist
fix them what about uh what about the
dancing have you had uh training in the
dance as we call it the dance yeah yes
um i have actually strangely enough i
took tap dancing lessons when i was a
kid oh me too did you seriously yeah get
out of town no i did when i was a kid i
studied very seriously for like four
years yeah
i'm not kidding oh oh well it's it's sad
when i say it
you know when i do it it's like oh my
god
or maybe a little sexy
[Laughter]
and uh no scary scary anyway go ahead
um yeah no there's a show on canadian
television i grew up in toronto and
there's a show on canadian television
called the pig and whistle
which was a uh is supposed to be like
somebody knows it from canada and to
hear it on american tv is just like
going what i've been transported it's a
it's a show that like is takes place on
a british pub set and it's like come in
to the pig again with i mean and they
have like cheeky chappy cockney dancers
like mary poppins
and uh i saw it as a kid and i i went to
my parents and i went i want to do that
and so i took tap dancing lessons from
these people uh-huh and uh they taught
you well they taught me how to do jazz
dancing and ballroom and cha-cha-cha
and i can tap dance and were you mocked
as a kid because i remember when i was a
kid and and and
well when i was a kid and i took tap
dance it's not the kind of thing you go
and and like tough kids are about to
beat you go wait a minute wait a minute
i'm cool i can tap i can buck and wing
yeah
no my brothers used to taunt me
mercilessly they called me tippy toes
for four years uh my brothers were just
completely torturous i mean i must have
drank in my lifetime at least a liter of
their urine
uh
i mean i swear
what's the connection there i don't see
it
tippy toes oh then it would be sort of
like mikey you want a mountain dew
you're such an idiot every time
every time
so now
i still have a bad association with
mountain dew you still you're not gonna
trust people if they say what do you got
in the fridge some mountain dew and i'm
like
not again